Je ne peux pas payer le loyer avec ces choses.
Cette citrouille, ces pièces d'Asgard, ils n'ont aucune valeur.
À Asgard, ces pièces valent des milliards de dollars humains.
Ok ?
Un milliard. T'es riche.
Un autre milliard. Encore un autre..
Personne ne voudra échanger ça.
Va au marché...
monte un stand avec écrit "Marchandise d'Asgard...
.. appartenant précédemment à Thor."
Je suis une célébrité, ça va se vendre comme des petits pains.
Tu as pensé à avoir un job ?
Un boulot ? Sérieux ?
J'ai un boulot
Mon boulot est de sauver la Planète.
Peut-être que c'est toi qui devrait trouver un boulot.
J'en ai un.
Ouais, tu veux dire appuyer sur l'ordinateur avec des mots qui en sortent...
"C'est la connaissance ! La connaissance, c'est la force."
Non, ça ne l'ai pas. La connaissance n'est pas la force.
Ça c'est la force !
Le cerveau est un muscle.
Et ça c'est un muscle, et ça aussi
Et ce sont tous des muscles !
Tout est en muscle !
Alors JE suis couvert de neurones.
Et j'ai plus de neurones que toi.
Alors tu penses que...
Je pense qu'on a besoin d'un serviteur.
Je ne pense pas qu'on puisse avoir de serviteur
On devrait en avoir un.
Parfait, c'est réglé on prend un serviteur !